The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TYLER JACKS: OK, good
morning everybody.
Morning.
Good morning, good morning.
All right, we're going to
continue our discussion
about cancer today
as well as on Friday.
In between you have
an exam on Wednesday.
Partly in preparation
for that I'm
having office hours tomorrow
between 3:00 and 4:00 in 76453.
And as the note says,
come with questions
that you have about
immunology, which I taught you,
and the introductory cancer
class that I taught you.
If you have questions
about other subjects
that will be
covered in this exam
that Professor [? Sid
?] covered for you,
it's best to go to her
office hours, or to your TAs,
or the other sections
that will be held.
All right so towards
the end of last lecture
we talked about
smoking and cancer,
and I warned you against
the evils of smoking.
And I hope you were
paying attention.
This slide shows you some
pretty startling statistics
that relate the increase
in smoking, shown here,
among men in this country,
which began around 1900.
And you can see it
rapidly increased over
the first part of
the last century.
And you can also see that about
20 years later lung cancer
rates rose equally quickly.
And this was some
of the evidence
that smoking caused lung cancer.
And we now know, as I
mentioned to you last time,
that there are lots of
carcinogens in cigarette smoke
that cause lung cancer.
Lots of mutagens.
Either mutagens in their
native form or promutagens
that can be converted
into mutagens, that we
expose ourselves to through
the process of tobacco smoking.
That was men.
But lung cancer has
also increased in women.
You can see this also
precipitous increase
in lung cancer among
women in this country.
And lung cancer has now
passed breast cancer
as the leading cause of
cancer deaths among women
in the United States.
You can see that
in the case of men,
smoking levels actually started
to drop quite some time ago.
And coincident with
that, lung cancer
deaths among men in this
country also have been dropping.
It's a direct result of
smoking cessation and people
not starting to smoke.
That had not happened
in the case of women
until very recently.
In fact, just last
month a study was
published that showed that also
for women lung cancer rates are
now starting to go down.
And that's a direct
consequence of the fact
that fewer women are smoking.
It takes a few years to
see that effect play out
because people who were
smoking 20 years ago
are getting cancer
based on that now.
So examples of why
smoking is bad for you.
Cigarette smoke
can be considered
a environmental carcinogen,
although it's one
that we expose ourselves to.
I talked to you
about a variety of
other environmental carcinogens
that we get exposed to.
I also described this
phenomenon by which
chemicals that are not in
their native state, mutagenic,
can become mutagenic through
metabolism in our bodies.
Promutagens can be converted
to mutagens in our body.
And I showed you the example
of benzo [a] pyrene which
is in cigarette smoke and gets
converted into a mutagenic form
in our bodies.
And there are many other such.
There are also examples, and
I didn't say this explicitly,
of nonmutagenic carcinogens.
This goes against the rule
that carcinogens are mutagens.
These are actually
nonmutagenic but they're
cancer causing so we
call them carcinogens.
Examples of this would
be alcohol and asbestos.
These affect cancer
rates, we think,
because they cause
tissue damage.
Alcohol in the
liver, for example,
causes tissue
damage in the liver.
Asbestos, if you breathe it
in, can cause tissue damage
in the linings of the lungs.
This tissue damage then results
in increased proliferation.
Cells are recruited
to grow in order
to repair the damage
that was caused,
and this can then indirectly
result in mutations.
Because as I mentioned to
you, every time your cell
divides there's a chance
that a problem will happen,
a chance that a replication
error will occur.
There's a chance that
an important gene
relevant to cancer
will incur a mutation.
So more replication, more
proliferation, the greater the
chance that a problematic
mutation will take place.
I didn't say this
explicitly, but likewise
problems in
chromosome segregation
can occur every
time a cell divides.
We have intricate systems
to ensure that chromosomes
separate properly so
that each daughter
cell gets the right
complement of chromosomes.
But sometimes that breaks down.
And sometimes cells get the
wrong number of chromosomes.
We talked about this in
the context of meiosis,
but non-disjunction events
can occur in mitosis as well,
leading to chromosome
imbalances, which
are also hallmarks of cancer.
As I showed you
last time, if you
look at the chromosome
content of a cancer cell
it is often very, very abnormal.
And these abnormal
chromosome numbers
occur due to defects in
chromosome segregation,
including
non-disjunction events.
OK, so various things that
we expose ourselves to
or that just go along with the
normal process of cell division
can lead to mutations.
And as I emphasized
in the last lecture,
cancer is the consequence
of the accumulation
of mutations in critical genes.
So to summarize what I
told you about last time,
we now think of the process
of cancer development
as going from a normal
cell through multiple steps
to the development
of malignant cells.
This process, for
most types of cancer,
will take years to accomplish.
Cells acquire these alterations
over multiple years.
And these arrows represent
mutations to cellular genes.
Mutations in processes that
are important in determining
the normal behavior
of these cells
and allowing these cells
to behave abnormally.
This process unfolds over
time, as I mentioned.
And gives rise to
this phenomenon,
or this hypothesis
really for which we have
great evidence now, the
so-called clonal evolution
of cancer, which I drew on
the board for you last time.
This is a nice version
of that same concept
from a figure from a book
from Bob Weinberg who teaches
this same class in the fall.
Here you have a row
of normal cells.
Within these cells
a mutation arises.
This mutation gives that
cell the ability to expand,
perhaps better than
its neighbor cells.
So a number of daughter
cells carrying this mutation
are born.
Within this now clone
of singly mutant cells,
a second mutation can arise,
say in this cell here.
This mutation, likewise,
confers upon these cells
a greater ability to
grow, divide, survive, out
compete their neighbors.
So you get a lot
of these cells too.
And then within that
expanded clone of cells,
a third mutation
arises, and so on.
Until one has enough patients
to have a fully malignant cell.
So what are the genes
that are relevant here?
Well, let's think
about the processes
that we know are important
in cancer development,
and those are listed
in the bottom right.
Proliferation is the
most obvious one.
Cells proliferate
abnormally in cancer.
So mutations in genes that
regulate proliferation
are likely to be important here.
Cancer is a disease of cell
number, too many cells.
You can get that because you
have too much proliferation,
but you can also get it if you
have too little cell death.
So mutations in genes that
regulate cell death processes
are also found in cancer.
I told you last time
about angiogenesis,
the process by which
blood vessels are
recruited into the tumor.
These two are recruited
by virtue of signals
that the tumor
sends, some of which
other product of mutations.
I told you that
cancer cells move
in the process of metastasis.
They break their interactions
with their neighbors
and they begin to move
throughout the tissue,
and ultimately
throughout the body.
So they have increased
cell motility.
And they also can invade.
They can invade through
the basement membrane.
They can invade into
the local tissue.
So they have increased
invasiveness.
And there are other changes that
take place within cancer cells.
And so these mutations
then collectively
increase proliferation,
decrease cell death,
increase angiogenesis,
increase motility,
and increase invasiveness.
It's important to know
about these because today we
are able to target some
of these mutations.
We are able to target
the gene products formed
by these mutant genes
and thereby create
better therapies.
So our goal is to understand
these processes such
that we can ultimately
control them more effectively
in the context of treatment.
OK well, that then leads
us to what are the genes?
What amongst the 22,000
genes in your genome
get mutated in the
development of cancer?
How can we find them?
Nowadays, we
sequence the genomes
of cancer cells, that's
how we find them.
But that's not always been true.
It's actually been true for
only the last few years.
And so I'll give you
some examples of how
they were found previously.
And why do we care?
Well, I've already
indicated some
of this a few minutes ago,
but the reason we care
to understand the disease
at the molecular level.
Ultimately we'll
be able to provide,
in very accurate detail,
improved diagnostic
information, improved
prognostic information.
We'll be able to tell
that an individual has
cancer by detecting abnormal
genes in their blood.
Circulating DNA in their blood
carrying specific mutations
associated with
particular cancers.
We'll be able to
diagnose the disease
at an earlier stage that way.
We'll be able to figure
out exactly what mutations
are present in the cancer
cell to know whether that's
a tumor that's going to
go on to kill the patient,
or sit there and do nothing.
Should we treat the
patient aggressively?
Or should we leave them alone?
Only with this molecular
information will be
will be able to figure
that out in detail.
We will, and we already,
use this information
to make better cancer
drugs, molecularly targeted
therapies that will replace
conventional chemotherapy,
which I'll teach
you about on Friday.
Chemotherapy can work, but
it's highly, highly toxic
and we'd like to be
able to get rid of it
and replace it with drugs that
are much more specific, much
more selective, and much less
harmful except for the cancer
cells.
And this will usher
in a new era, which
I would argue is already here
in some small way, called
personalized medicine.
The individual's disease
will be diagnosed
at the molecular level
and a specific therapy
will be designed for them
based on those alterations.
We'll dial up the right therapy
based on that information.
And again, hopefully,
hopefully, yield better results
and less toxic side effects.
Cancer is leading
the way, actually,
in personalized medicine.
But it will be true
for lots of diseases
in the not too distant future.
OK, so what are the genes?
Well, I'm going to introduce you
to two broad classes of genes
today.
The first of which
are called oncogenes.
Onco for mass, genes.
Oncogenes, cancer
genes, cancer causing
genes of one sort or another.
The first of these oncogenes
was identified in the context
of oncogenic viruses.
For example, rous sarcoma
virus, which is a retrovirus.
We'll learn more
about those next week.
Retroviruses are viruses
with an RNA genome.
HIV falls into the same class.
Rous sarcoma virus,
or RSV, has been
studied since about 1910 or so.
It was discovered
by a virologist
at Rockefeller University
by the name of Peyton Rous.
Peyton Rous was a virologist
and a Long Island chicken farmer
came to Peyton Rous with a
prize hen from his collection.
A prize hen that had
a tumor mass growing
on its breast muscle.
And the farmer brought
this hen to Peyton Rous
and asked him to cure
the hen because it
was very valuable to him
Peyton Rous took the hen.
The farmer said, thank you.
The farmer went away.
Peyton Rous then promptly killed
the hen and isolated the tumor.
And was able to isolate
from the tumor a virus.
A virus that could infect
another bird and cause
cancer in that bird.
So this was the first
example of a virus associated
with tumor development.
There have since
been many examples
of viruses associated with tumor
development in animal species.
A few examples in people,
but relatively few.
Most cancers in humans are not
virus associated but some are,
like human papilloma virus
associated cervical cancer
as an example.
But these viruses studied
in laboratory animals
were extremely important
in teaching us about how
cancers arise normally.
It was known using
rous sarcoma virus
that if you took a
normal chicken cell,
fibroblasts from a chicken and
infected it with rous sarcoma
virus, it would cause those
cells to round up and begin
to proliferate abnormally.
And these cells were given a
term called being transformed.
Transformed cells that had the
appearance of cancer cells.
After that work, a
great deal of effort
went into figuring out what
were the genes of rous sarcoma
virus that allowed the virus
to cause those cells to become
transformed.
And it was determined
that the virus carries
a single gene called
SRC, S-R-C, for sarcoma,
which is responsible for
this transformation process.
You could basically
just add the SRC gene
and the same
process would occur.
Trying to understand
the origins of the SRC,
two investigators at UCSF,
Mike Bishop and Harold Varmus
in around 1975, determined that
the SRC gene had a homologue,
a related copy,
in chicken cells.
And they went on to
hypothesize correctly
that rous sarcoma virus stole
this gene from the chicken
cells that it was infecting and
incorporated into its genome.
So the SRC gene, this cancer
gene, had a cellular origin.
Moreover, they were able to show
that SRC exists in human cells.
And this was quite shocking.
This cancer associated gene
was present in our DNA.
This discovery led
Bishop and Varmus
to win the Nobel Prize in 1989.
And a funny story
happened that day.
This is a true story.
I actually worked for
Varmus as a PhD student,
so I heard it from
the horse's mouth.
Varmus's sister-in-law was
standing in a cafeteria line
at Berkeley waiting
to get her lunch
and two guys were
standing in front of her.
And one guy said
to the other what
are you going to have today?
And the guy said, I
don't really know.
And the first guy said,
well don't get the chicken
because two guys just won
the Nobel Prize for showing
that chicken causes cancer.
This is sometimes how the
public perceives what we do.
But anyway, they went
on to win the Nobel
Prize for this important work.
And they proposed
that there were
genes in our DNA,
which they referred
to as proto-oncogenes,
which could undergo
mutation and become oncogenes.
In the case of RSV,
the mutation was
to take the gene
out of the genome
and stick it in the
genome of a virus.
But as we'll see today, there
are other ways to do that too.
Now, what the heck are we
doing with proto-oncogenes
in our genomes?
What are these
genes doing there?
Why do we have the SRC gene?
Why do we have other such genes?
Who can tell me?
Why is it beneficial to have a
cancer causing gene in our DNA?
What might these genes be doing?
AUDIENCE: They might be just
for normal metabolic processes.
TYLER JACKS: Yeah, normal
metabolic processes.
Or perhaps normal proliferation.
Our cells divide too.
You go from a single cell when
you're at fertilization to 10
to the 13 cells.
It's a lot of cell division.
That's a controlled process.
There's lots of genes
that are devoted
to teaching your
cells what to do
when they're supposed to do it.
And these genes are presumably
involved in those normal cell
division processes
but they get corrupted
in the context of cancer.
They get altered so they
don't work properly.
OK.
So RSV was the first example,
SRC was the first example.
But it still led to some
skepticism, some concern that
in fact what was seen in
the context of these viruses
might not be relevant
to real human cancer.
Which as I told you
a few minutes ago,
rarely involves viral infection.
And so along came Bob Weinberg
who was, and is still, at MIT.
His lab is in the
Whitehead Institute.
And Weinberg did a
critical experiment.
He started with an individual.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry about that.
This is a person.
Sort of.
And this individual
had bladder cancer.
Weinberg isolated the DNA
from the bladder cancer
to ask the question, were
there cancer genes in there?
Were there oncogenes in there?
Were there mutationally
altered genes
which the reason that
this tumor arose?
And so he did an experiment.
He took this isolated DNA and
he introduced it into some cells
in the laboratory.
These were immortalized
mouse cells.
Immortalize meaning that they
would grow in the lab forever.
Which by the way, is not normal.
Normally you take
cells out of your body
or out of a mouse,
put them in the lab,
they'll grow for a
while but they'll
stop growing eventually.
These cells were immortal.
They could continue to grow.
But they were otherwise
pretty well-behaved.
They laid flat on the dish.
They had normal
boundaries between cells.
They were non-transformed.
They didn't look
like cancer cells.
And they were non-tumorigenic.
If he introduced these cells
into an experimental animal
they wouldn't cause a tumor, OK.
They were immortalized
but they were otherwise
pretty well-behaved.
He introduced the isolated
DNA from the tumor cell
through a process
call transfection,
where basically the DNA gets
sheared up and introduced
into the cells such
that, roughly speaking
each cell is getting
individual genes spread out
amongst this population
of mouse cells.
And then he waited.
And what he found was
that at low frequency,
whereas most of the cells state
in their normal morphology,
occasionally he got this.
[PHONE RINGING]
Can somebody get that?
A transformed colony of cells.
And he assumed, correctly,
that this colony
arose because one
of these genes was
a cancer gene that allowed these
cells to divide abnormally.
He further could show that
if he took those cells
and introduced
them into an animal
they would now cause a tumor.
So they were not
just transformed,
they were also tumorigenic.
He went on to isolate
the human gene.
Which was not difficult to do
because the cells themselves
were mouse, so he's looking
for the human DNA sequence.
And he found, eventually,
that it was a mutant version
of a gene called RAS.
A gene that you've actually
learned about already in class.
And I'll tell you more
about in a second.
This discovery made
by Weinberg's lab
and a few other labs at the
same time in the early 1980's is
the reason I'm
standing before you.
When I was your age
Weinberg came to my college
and gave a lecture on this work.
And I was so excited
about the potential
of learning about cancer
at the molecular level
that I decided
right then and there
to start working on cancer,
and have been doing ever since.
So sometimes the things
you learn in class
actually change your life.
Not to say that's
going to happen today,
but sometimes it does.
OK, so Weinberg isolates
the RAS oncogene
from these bladder cancer Cells.
They went on to
sequence the gene
to determine how it was
different from the normal copy
of RAS.
And that's illustrated here.
Here's the normal RAS sequence.
This is now not working.
It's a version of
RAS called H-RAS.
That's insignificant.
You can see the codons,
the encoded amino acids.
Here's the change that has taken
place within the cancer cells.
They didn't have a
G in this position,
instead they had a
T in this position.
This gene wouldn't encode
glycine like it's supposed to
but instead valene at
codon position number 12.
This change, this single
nucleotide change,
this single amino
acid substitution
caused this signaling protein
to go from a regulatable state
as shown here.
And hopefully this
is familiar to you
because you learned about it
already in the signaling part
of cell biology.
RAS is a GTP binding
protein, which normally
cycles between an active GTP
bound state and an inactive GDP
bound state.
It goes from on to off through
this hydrolysis of GTP.
In the context of this
mutation the GDP hydrolysis
is inhibited.
So the protein stays in
its GTP bound active state.
It gets stuck on.
And rather than signaling
in a regulated fashion,
signals constitutively.
Rather than telling the cells
to divide when they should,
it tells the cells
to divide always.
And that's presumably
why this mutation
is selected for in this type of
cancer and many, many others.
OK, I remind you that RAS is
a signal transduction pathway.
Here's RAS itself.
RAS interacts with upstream
receptor molecules and growth
factors.
There are intermediary
adapter proteins
that help that interaction.
There are downstream signaling
proteins, like kinases.
And ultimately there are
nuclear transcription factors
and target genes
that they regulate.
This is a signaling cascade.
And actually what
we learn in cancer
is that many of these
genes, not just RAS,
but many of these genes can
be mutated in the development
of one or more cancers.
For example, some genes
like these are amplified.
And I'll tell you more
about that in a second.
Others are the product
of translocation
so that they're
expressed abnormally.
Others have structural
mutations like deletions.
And others have very
subtle mutations.
The RAS mutation is
a subtle mutation.
It's a single nucleotide
change that allows this gene
to function abnormally.
OK, so importantly oncogenes
dominantly transform cells.
Weinberg added a
single mutant oncogene
and it transformed
those mouse cells.
The mutations are a gain
of function mutations.
They're dominant mutations.
Gain of function mutations.
There are now about 300
or so, and the number
is growing, known oncogenes.
Within the 22,000 genes in
your genomes, about 300 of them
can be converted to an
oncogenic form through mutation.
What types of
mutations do we find?
Well I've listed
them on that slide
but I'll just write
it down as well.
Subtle mutations, RAS
is the classic example.
A single amino acid change
will convert the protein
to an oncogenic form.
We can also find
gene amplifications.
Your genes are present at
two per cell, one from mom,
one from dad.
You're supposed to have two.
Sometimes in cancer
amplification
of regions of the DNA occur.
So you go from having not
two, but four, eight, 50, 100
copies of the gene.
And you can imagine having
too many copies, leading
to too much protein
product, would actually lead
to inappropriate signaling.
So here the structural
gene may not be mutated,
the amino acid sequence
may be the same.
You've just got too much of it.
Also, genes can be rearranged.
Gene rearrangements.
For example, translocations.
And I showed you some
pictures of translocations.
Chromosomes that get joined
inappropriately together.
This can break two genes
and form a new gene
in the context of
the translocation.
Perhaps a gene is expressed
from a weakly acting promoter,
normally.
But because of a
translocation event
a very strongly
acting promoter gets
stuck in front of
that gene by mistake.
And now the gene is expressed
at very high levels,
inappropriately.
It's not unlike the consequences
of gene amplification.
So translocations,
likewise, occur frequently.
And we'll hear about
consequences of amplification
and re-arrangement next time
when we talk about therapies.
OK, so oncogenes act dominantly.
They can transform
cells all by themselves.
But this should be in your
minds creating confusion.
Because I've also told you that
cancer is a multi-step process.
And if cancer were a
multi-step process,
how could it be that single
mutations can transform cells?
But in fact, we now know
that single mutations
are typically and maybe
never sufficient to produce
true cancer.
So given that, can
somebody explain how
the Weinberg experiment worked?
How was it that Weinberg was
able to transfer a single gene
into these cells and cause
them to become transformed
and tumorigenic if single
mutations aren't enough?
Why did this work?
Anybody?
The key is that they
weren't normal cells.
The cells he started with
are already abnormal.
They were already immortalized.
They'd already been
growing in the laboratory
dish for a long time.
So they were sensitive
to a single mutation
but normal cells in
your body are not.
And that's a good thing.
Because as you sit
there today you probably
have about a million RAS
mutant cells in your body,
scattered around.
And that's just based on the
normal mutation frequency.
The likelihood is
that we all have
about a million or more RAS
mutant cells in our body.
But because RAS
mutations are not
sufficient to drive
cancer formation, that
may be in a tumor initiated cell
but it's not yet a full cancer,
other mutations have to
take place thereafter.
We now believe that
there's probably
something like three
to 20 mutations
are required to make
a full blown cancer.
OK, so I've told
you about oncogenes
and I've related their function
to normal cell division,
and that's appropriate to do.
Normal cells do get
signals to divide,
make more of themselves.
And moreover, they get
signals to stop dividing
when it's time to stop.
In embryogenesis once
you form the liver
you want to stop cell division
within the liver cells.
When you wound yourself you
recruit cells to divide,
but once the wound is healed
you want it to stop dividing.
And so there's complimentary
signals, stop signals,
that come into play to
cause the cells to stop.
Cancer cells have
defects in both
of these classes of signals.
We've been talking now
about the oncogene signals.
They are the go Signals.
The signals to tell
the cell to divide.
And because of these
alterations like in RAS
the cells are more
capable of dividing.
They make more of themselves.
Moreover, the brakes on this
process, the stop signals,
are also typically lost in
the development of cancer.
Such that now the cells
lacking the breaking signals
will continue to
divide still more.
And these two
classes of genes are
called oncogenes, that we've
been discussing already,
and tumor suppressor genes
that we'll discuss from now
to the end of the lecture.
Tumor suppressor genes.
There are a number of
tumor suppressor genes
now as well, more
than 200 known.
So that's 500 or so known
cancer genes already.
The first one,
the very first one
described occurred in
this type of tumor.
This is a child with
a tumor of the eye.
The tumor is called
retinoblastoma.
And based on the examination
of the genes within those tumor
cells, it was hypothesized that
the retinoblastoma gene that
was responsible for
this disease was
one of these tumor suppressor
genes before any of them
were actually known.
That led ultimately to the
cloning of the RB gene,
the retinoblastoma
susceptibility gene called RB.
Also in Bob Weinberg's lab.
Which encodes a
protein called pRB.
And further work in
Weinberg's lab and many others
showed why cells get
rid of the RB gene
in the development of
that cancer as well
as other cancers.
The RB gene is now-- or the
protein that it encodes--
is now known to be an important
regulator of the cell cycle.
We learned about the cell cycle.
Cells go from my mitosis G1,
into S phase, and then G2,
and then into mitosis again.
This is a regulated process.
And the RB gene or protein is
important in controlling it.
The RB protein acts here by
blocking the transition from G1
into S, and I'll
tell you a bit more
how it does so in a moment.
This is when the protein
is in its active state.
It can be inactivated
through phosphorylation.
A phosphate group, actually
many phosphate groups,
can be transferred
onto the RB gene
through kinases, which are
stimulated by growth promoting
signals.
Growth factor binding to
a cell will ultimately
result in the stimulation
of these kinases
to phosphorylate the
RB protein, taking it
from this active state to its
phosphorylated state, which
is inactive.
So the break is released
because the kinases inactivate
the break, OK.
Just a little bit
more detail about RB.
A lot is known about
this process now.
This transition from
G1 into S requires
some transcription factors
called E2F transcription
factors.
And RB binds and inactivates
the RB transcription factors,
keeping them silent.
When it's an active state
RB has a little pocket
to which the E2F
transcription factors bind.
Here's pRB, and here are the
E2F transcription factors
and they are sequestered
by the RB protein
and can't otherwise
do their job.
But when RB gets
phosphorylated by those kinases
these phosphate groups interfere
with the binding of E2F,
and E2F is then liberated to
carry out its normal function
driving this transition.
OK.
So this is how the
break functions and it's
a very, very important break.
RB is mutated in a very high
percentage of cancer cells,
not just retinoblastomas
but many others as well.
And the pathway that
it is controlled by
is likewise mutated
in a high frequency.
Tumor suppressor genes,
like RB, are the breaks.
They negatively
regulate proliferation.
As such, are these
genes normally hyper
activated or
inactivated in cancer?
Hyper activated or inactivated?
Inactivated.
That's in contrast to the
oncogenes which get activated,
hyper activated.
These get inactivated or lost.
These inactivating
mutations are recessive.
They are loss of
function, again,
in contrast to the
situation with oncogenes
which are dominant
mutations, gain of function.
And this actually creates an
interesting challenge for us.
If these are recessive
mutations and a cell
acquires a mutation in
one copy of the RB gene--
and I'll just show the
chromosomes on which RB exists.
Happens to be chromosome 13.
We have a normal cell, say it's
a normal cell in the developing
retina.
And that cell incurs a mutation.
Random chance,
cigarette smoking,
probably not in this
child, but random chance.
Leads to the inactivation
of one copy of the RB gene.
What's the phenotype
of this cell?
It's normal.
These are recessive mutations.
Having one normal copy
is sufficient to provide
RB protein, to provide
control of the cell cycle.
So the cell is
normal but the cell
is predisposed
because now it only
has one functional copy left.
We could call this
the first mutation.
And now within
this clone of cells
if a second mutation occurs
then we're in trouble.
And the second mutation
can occur in one
of a couple of different ways.
For example, it could be that
by random chance, bad luck
the normal copy on the other
chromosome gets mutated.
Or it could be, and it's
actually more frequent,
that a chromosomal
event takes place.
For example, a cell arises
which only has one chromosome 13
through chromosomal
non-disjunction.
And it's the one
with the mutant copy.
These are functionally
equivalent.
Both of these cells
are RB deficient.
And they are on their
way to becoming cancers.
Tumor suppressor genes
therefore require two hits.
Two hits, two mutational
events to inactivate the two
normal copies of the gene.
They can be two
mutations within the gene
or they can be one
mutation within the gene
plus some chromosomal event.
And I've shown you one example
here, there are others.
OK.
So that looks good.
Everybody gets it
right, no problems?
Let me show you this picture,
which I actually showed you
on the first day of class.
This is a child
who has bilateral,
multi-focal retinoblastoma.
This child has 12 different
retinoblastoma tumors
affecting both eyes.
Not only that, this
child comes from a family
in which retinoblastoma
is passing
through the generations.
The grandfather had it, he
passed on the predisposition
to multiple of his children,
who passed on the predisposition
to multiple of their children.
This is an example of a
familial cancer syndrome.
Familial predisposition
to cancer.
Most cancers don't have
this kind of pedigree.
Most cancers are sporadic,
but about 10% of cancers
look like this with a
clear family history.
Familial retinoblastoma,
familial breast cancer,
familial colon cancer,
and there are others.
These are caused by
mutations in genes like this.
This individual
that I showed you,
the individuals in
this family have
inherited a defective
copy of the gene
from one of their parents.
And as such they
have this genotype.
They are heterozygous
for an RB mutation.
Heterozygous for an RB mutation.
And because they're
heterozygous for an RB mutation
they are highly predisposed
to developing retinoblastoma.
And the reason is that
within their cells,
within the developing
retinal cells in their body
two mutational events
are not required.
Instead in them, all of
their cells look like this.
All of their cells are in that
heterozygous predisposed state.
And therefore in
them, a single hit
is required to give rise
to a cell that is lacking
the function of RB altogether.
And that's why
they're predisposed.
And that's why BRCA1
patients get breast cancer,
and why APC patients get
familial colon cancer.
This slide also raises for
you some interesting questions
and we'll talk about
them next time.
Here's a person who
has the right genotype
but he didn't get the disease.
Why not?
And another question,
what would happen
if two individuals who were
heterozygous for the mutation
were to marry, have a child who
was homozygous for an RB gene
mutation?
What would happen then?
We'll talk about that next time.